hello it's a cold open this week because
we have a bit of news the first bit of
news is that dear Hank and John as well
as the anthropocene reviewed and a new
podcast called scishow tangents are all
going to be joining the WNYC family yeah
WNYC Studios is a as you may have heard
an organization that makes and produces
and works with lots of great podcasts
and we are joining them this podcast is
it will change basically nothing for you
just for clarity and will make things
easier for us and more stable for us and
also potentially help us make better
content and maybe even some other
projects in the future yeah we're huge
fans and have been for a long time of
WNYC they make podcasts like radio lab
and more perfect and Nancy in fact I've
known our producer at WNYC for more than
20 years all of which means this is
really exciting for us but should not
affect your listening experience that
much except insofar as the quality of
the audio might improve slightly yeah if
you think that this is gonna result in
like a fundamentally better dear Hank
and John experience I've got news for
you this is as good as it could possibly
be no yeah we're good we've reached it
we're keeping the podcast crap don't
worry about that but thank you to all of
you who listen every week it means the
world to us I also want to say that
we're going on tour Hank is going on a
longer tour that I'm going on but I will
be with Hank when an absolutely
remarkable thing comes out in New York
on Tuesday September 25th we'll be in
Boston on Wednesday September 26 John
and I will also be in Canton Ohio
Chicago Illinois Kansas City Missouri
and Indianapolis Indiana and then I'm
moving on by myself and gonna have some
special guests in Milwaukee Wisconsin
Denver Los Angeles San Diego Santa Cruz
and Bellingham Washington so if you're
in or near any of those places please
come see me and if you're in Missoula
Montana I'll probably do a local event
too but it will be separate and not part
of this tour so we hope to see lots of
you on tour now is the time to get
tickets by the way because many of the
shows are very close to selling out I am
so excited for a Hank's book an
absolutely remarkable thing it comes out
on September 25th it is available for
free
now I can only say that for a few more
days because soon it will just be
available for order anyway let's roll
the open hello and welcome to dear Hank
and John Lourdes I prefer to think of it
dear Johnny Hank it's a comedy podcast
where two brothers answer your questions
give you the B's advice and making all
the week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon John yeah how do we start this
podcast again you tell a dad joke we
have never been so unprepared sarah has
been out of town for the last five days
and i am i sorry my circadian rhythms
are completely off when Sarah is gone
like I go to bed at two o'clock in the
morning and then I have to wake up and
take the kids to school and the kids are
like what's wrong with you dad and I'm
just like I I just I I thank God let
Hank sorry
what just happened my circadian are also
messed up they're buzzin all in my brain
because I just got back from Australia
and so I spent the hours of 12 to 3
o'clock in the morning this this last
day awake very hungry and and eventually
eating quite a lot of Turkey cold guts
but but we start the podcast with a dad
joke yeah so John yeah what noise does a
747 make when it bounces what noise does
a 747 make when it bounces Boeing Boeing
don't worry don't worry next week's dad
joke is even better than that one I got
a bunch of collected already it's great
I'm very excited about this new format
oh my god the Great Barrier Reef is
showing signs of recovery in good news
that's wonderful I had heard that it was
showing signs of the opposite of that
well don't worry there has been massive
coral bleaching in 2016 and 2017 however
due to a milder 2017-2018 summer you'll
recall that down in Australia summer you
know goes yep right as well as a lot of
cooperation
lots of different groups there has been
some recovery in the Great Barrier Reef
now the long-term worry is still that
these uh you know mild summers may not
be a permanent phenomenon so it's good
news but if we don't stop stop no no
it's just good news job don't its global
warming me okay it's good news it's good
news egg let's move on to some questions
for listeners the worst the worst job
we've ever done I mean we have an
episode called the worst episode ever
but we might have to update it yeah I
know that we had we yeah well the good
news is that we can always do worse all
right Hank we're gonna answer some
questions from our listeners and we're
gonna do a good job of it because I just
gave you a pep talk then I think Nikki
cut out of the podcast but doesn't curse
words in it was a profanity-laden
halftime team talk where I was like Hank
we've got to get into the podcast right
now this question comes from Mary Kate
who asks Dear John and Hank I own a tank
top that simply says Tuesday on it in
big block letters I've owned it for a
while now but I don't wear it very often
because I only feel it's appropriate to
wear on Tuesdays however I really like
the color and comfort of this tank top
should I wear the tank top on days other
than Tuesday or that will that just
confuse people dubious advice
appreciated Ashley's sister Mary Kate oh
my god it's from mary-kate Olsen
mary-kate Olsen wrote into the pod to
ask us a fashion question that is a
surprise that is a surprise I so so I
mean maybe you should approach this as
if you are actually mary-kate Olsen
which I'm not saying you aren't right
but say like look I am a just a
tremendously successful actress and
businessperson and I have done things
that no one else has done before and I
was in that very good music video about
pizza and I can do whatever I want I
and mary-kate Olsen I just punched my
microphone a little bit yeah we I can
feel the passion yeah you just gotta ask
yourself mary-kate w WM k OD yeah well
what would mary-kate Olsen do in the
situation the answer is that she would
wear that tank top yeah almost she'd
probably wear it once because she has a
lot of outfits she'd set that trend man
you got it what you got to do is get a
one for every day of the week but then
never wear them on the right day right
yeah no that's what my son does with his
day of the week underwear that's very
it's a it's a Power Move you just
everybody will respect you cuz they'll
be like I'm just very confused with
mary-kate is around yeah you know what
you wanna know a fascinating fact about
mary-kate Olsen tank sure I mean always
mary-kate Olsen is 32 years old
oh wow do you know how old a SH Lee
Olson is you really you really sold that
one next question
there's a bunch of people out there by
the way who have no idea who mary-kate
and Ashley Olsen are yeah do not know
that they are twins did not get that
joke until I just explained that they
are twins now you know for context the
reason it's so alarming to Hank and me
that mary-kate and Ashley Olsen are 32
years old is they don't need to continue
explaining yes I know Hank just look it
up if you're confused look at all hanck
jokes get funnier when you explain them
more everyone knows that that's one of
those next question comes from ward shut
you up
my mom just started a choir with her
colleagues from work and they are
terrible they practice at home and it's
hard to avoid the noise this on its own
isn't a problem I'm glad that you think
so Ward you can always put the podcast
in but Ward says I sing in a pretty good
choir myself so my mom sees me as the
authority on choir music and asks for my
advice or to listen for mistakes if I
would be honest I would say the whole
thing is a mistake but they're clearly
having fun and I don't want to ruin it
for them how do I give advice that
doesn't hurt feelings but is still
somewhat helpful
Ward and of the North Hank before I
answer this question can I just note
that maybe we've been doing such a
terrible job of the pod so far because
we're trying to reassure people that the
fact that we're now a fancy WNYC podcast
does not mean that we're gonna be good
so we're partnering with WNYC and we
want to give you a really subpar product
right now so you don't think anything's
changing Ward you have to tell your
mother I'm glad you're having fun it
sounds like you're having fun
and things that are technically true
while also not being cruel and if she
asks you how is the quality of our
singing you can say like I mean I don't
think that your professional choir but I
don't think you're trying to be you're
having fun Ward maybe you should go to I
don't know someone who is more expert
than us like your choir director who is
a person that you I assume know and can
lay out the sitch and and say like you
know that like that person is probably
aware of how to deal with with singers
at all levels and maybe there is some
some insight you can get from there but
I think John's right like ultimately
things like this don't have to be about
perfection they can be about fun and and
so keep that in mind and you know be
supportive of the fun that you're that
the people in your lives want to have
Hank I think it's terrible advice to go
to your choir director or to go to
anyone with more expertise than we have
because all that does is undercut our
brand as providing high quality advice
on a variety of topics that we have no
expertise in yeah because it's like yeah
because I really can't tell you how to
direct a choir award tell mary-kate
Olsen how to wear a tank top but that's
not sewing it down I can totally do that
because i have worn tank tops John I've
done that I've never directed a choir
okay I I would submit that you are not
an expert in wearing tank tops based on
every single time I have ever seen you
wear a tank top when was the last time
you saw me wear a tank top it's been a
long time but it is seared in my memory
because
you do not look I say this with a lot of
respect and admiration for you as a
person but you cannot pull off a tank
top I think that most of the time when I
put on tank tops they look good if I'm
also wearing a shirt underneath is that
right
[Laughter]
Mary Kate whatever Hank said about when
to wear your Tuesday tank top you need
to do the opposite I don't know it's
just like it kind of like tugs the shirt
on to you more firmly and then you've
got sort of a you know a real good
situation on the top half yeah you were
an undershirt over your regular shirt
that's why they call it an over shirt
doing that every day of tour now my new
thank God tops please don't do that
it'd be like hello I'm a name is Hank
I'm a very serious author man you could
tell because of its like how Neil Gaiman
like started wearing leather all the
time and they were like Neil Gaiman is
like the cool leather guy he's like
author he's awesome and he like writes
really good books but also he's like
cool-looking and maybe a little bit like
I'm a little afraid because he's like I
don't know there was some kind of like
dark vibe going on there but I'm gonna
be the guy and like the tank top over
the t-shirt and people are gonna think
something about that yeah they'll think
something about it and that's all that
matters John that people are thinking
something about me it's the only
commodity we have left that is genuinely
what an absolutely remarkable thing is
about so I guess it would be on brand
this next question comes from Kelly who
writes Dear John and Hank what is the
worst snack you've ever had I asked
because the world needs more cautionary
tales on bad snacks on a road trip I
once had a bag of fish jerky and washed
it down with stevia-sweetened root beer
many repaid don't say anything bad about
stevia-sweetened root beer Kelly come on
fish jerky is not a thing is it that's
the worst thing I've ever heard
you know can we can we can direct the
Flav the the flavor part I want more of
the flavor part No
oh my god no the worst snack that I've
ever had by a very wide margin when
Sarah and I started dating
she was working at an art gallery and I
went to all of the art gallery shows
because I wanted her to like me and one
of them was a performance piece I don't
like I like performance art like the
idea of it I don't like experiencing
performance art because a lot of times
the artist interacts with the audience
which is the thing that makes me most
uncomfortable in the entire world mm-hmm
so it's like being at a play where you
are told five seconds before the play
starts that you are in fact an actor in
the play and there was this artist and
he was interacting with the audience and
he was sort of like weaving around them
and he would get his face really up
close to your face and I would you'd
have to like not scrunch your face in
fear because you wanted to look like you
were cool and a regular person and not
the kind of person you know who thinks
that when people are in your personal
space and then he handed me a piece of
candy and I was like huh yeah okay and
everyone else was unwrapping their candy
so I was like fine okay I'll unwrap my
candy and everyone else put it in their
mouths and I was like oh god I gotta put
this strange man's candy in my mouth and
I put it in my mouth and it was crab
flavored
oh man that god I thought it was just
gonna be regular candy and it was the
worst snack because the strange man put
it into your mouth but it was crab candy
candy was crab candy it was crab candy
and I mean I had to sit there and suck
on this crab candy for like 12 minutes
because I didn't want to be rude and
spit it out oh that's the the societal
pressure is amazing John it will it will
make you do anything there are so many
things that we will do because it just
seems like it's what's expected of us
and this is the most extreme example
I've ever heard of that afterwards the
artist was completely normal and he was
just like hanging out having a glass of
wine with menu it's like what'd you
think of the candy and I was like yeah
no I mean yeah it was good sure you
didn't say it was bad no just as I told
Ward not to tell his mom that her choir
is bad
but the guy didn't make the candy I
what's the worst snack you ever had
what's the worst snack I ever had I
don't know let's so in these like brief
moments before I'm officially sponsored
by Metamucil before before the before I
sign the contract they make these little
Metamucil wafers that are supposed to be
cookies yeah that's a huge lie like
people in my office eat them because
Metamucil sent sent us a bunch of them
if you are very hungry
they are food right but I find them to
be much less enjoyable than just the
normal Metamucil powder because you just
like the whole experience stays in your
mouth for a much longer time and you
have to be careful if you put the whole
thing in there at once it expands man
that's the whole point of of psyllium
husk is that it gets bigger and it
absorbs a lot of water and then suddenly
you're like I can't my mouth is now all
this and nothing have you put two of
those things in your mouth you might not
live there's a warning on the box I'm
not even kidding I can't wait till you
are in an actual television commercial
for this actual product and here like a
Metamucil wafers they're delicious don't
eat too though John I you also left on
the the last half of this question first
of all I looked up fish jerky it's
totally a thing and actually it's pretty
good I saw some I was like that's not
doesn't look bad and it was $25 and you
get free shipping if you pay the whole
you better but I do also have to bring
up that the situation was made even less
palatable for Kelly by the 100-plus
coyotes cats baking in the trunk of
their car which they were transporting
for thesis research and also the NAMM
specific sign off is Cheers
smelly Kelly I just didn't want to like
leave that knot in everybody's brains
because I'm happy that it was in mine I
just think that people do such important
work John and sometimes it means
transporting a lot a lot of coyote poop
can you
like how unexpected a turn of events it
must be for one of those mice that got
eaten by that coyote that then got
pooped out that then ended up in Kelly's
trunk laboratory somewhere but the good
news is that the mouse does not know
about that well we don't know that for
sure like watching for your house oven
being like take me to buy people's
burial grounds oh man imagine like a
spirit world where mice cannot rest
until until they've been taken to the
right place you know I can't tell if
this is offensive to religious people
even though I am a religious person all
right this next question comes from
Emily who writes dear John and Hank I've
been in a relationship with someone for
almost 10 months now Hank do you
remember when you countered your
relationship by months literally no no I
do not I remember like celebrating my
six-month anniversary with Sarah which
now it does seem a little ludicrous but
it's great you should count by months I
owe you counted by months we're in like
month 190 it is currently going really
well and I have hopes it may continue
for a very long time together we are
going to a common friend's wedding in a
month should I join the rest of the
ladies to try to catch the bouquet my
partner and I are nowhere near talking
about marriage and the risk of actually
catching it is stressful on the other
hand I want to participate in the
celebration traditions advice especially
dubious advice is appreciated pumpkins
and penguins Emily Jonah witnessed a lot
a lot like surprising number of bouquet
tosses in my time and I can tell you
something about every single one of them
the person who catches that bouquet
wanted to catch it a hundred percent
nobody ever catches it by accident
there's there's been fights and and if
it comes down to it just give it a tip
and be like oh I didn't get
are you knock it into somebody else's
hand yeah Emily you just line up to be
part of the bouquet catching and then
you don't catch the bouquet I have to
say of the wedding traditions this is
the one that I find the weirdest and at
our own wedding
Sarah was like I really don't want to do
this and there were other forces in the
wedding that were like you're gonna do
it so she did yeah but it is it's a
weird tradition I don't I don't just
like this one John there's I've seen one
I have been to a lot of weddings where
the the groom has to put a garter belt
on to the bride in front of everyone
oh yeah it's much worse to me yeah and
every like inch above the knee is a
decade of happy marriage or something
and I'm just like no yeah yeah there are
children here I'm very uncomfortable I
feel like that one's mostly going away
let me propose to you a potential
situation though in in which emily is
not the only one who feels this way and
is in fact that all of the people feel
this way and that's the the bouquet just
just like folks like goes a nice little
arc and then just like woo and
everybody's sort of like jumping up and
down and then it just falls straight to
the ground in a circle of people being
like I didn't know on it nobody wanted
it and that's okay let me propose that
that would be that would be a sort of
remarkable and exciting thing to have
happen not like embarrassing it would be
very funny and I think that that's fine
yeah I mean let's read for that outcome
nobody gets the bouquet everybody dies
alone or or our fate is not decided by a
bunch of flowers and in fact you can
have a completely fulfilling life
without romance in your life so yeah
lots of reasons to not catch the bouquet
unless you want to catch it then do I'm
not here to judge your bouquet strategy
I just think you can line up and choose
whether to catch it when the moment
comes this next question comes from Ken
who asks dear Hank and John can I take
apples off the ground there's a house
across the street from me that has an
apple tree and there are so many apples
that just fall off and sit there are
they mine now I think that the tree
grows more apples than a person could
possibly
but I don't know how many people live at
that house maybe there's like an army in
there packed in like a clown car apples
and aardvarks can I'm glad you're
exploring all the options ken the thing
the thing is good if there is an army
inside of this house yeah I'd be
concerned you would think that they
would be eating the apples right well I
would think that I am worried that this
person is hoarding an army and so I want
to deprive them of resources great point
Hank we need to make sure that there are
no well-organized private militias in
the United States trying to take over
our apple orchards and possibly the rest
of our country that's right that's right
and why else would you need that many
apples I mean give me a reason
justify your some apple tree owner Apple
farming apple cider make making or just
an apple tree got bigger than they
expected I mean isn't it possible that
this person just runs an extremely small
apple farm and that Kim is essentially
trying to steal their livelihood from
them there on the ground once they're on
the ground they're questionable as to
whether ken should eat them for health
reasons oh I'm not worried about that at
all but I don't know I was I was
thinking about this question because I
was thinking now if somebody were in my
garden and a tomato were on the ground
and they picked that tomato I would be
mad because I not because they picked
the tomato but because why are you in my
garden ken yeah but if it falls on the
other side of the fence that's fair game
there is a lot of ya around in my town
right now and frankly it their the the
the town doesn't even let you plant
fruit trees in the boulevards anymore
because like no one picks the fruit and
it just sits there and gets stinky and
then the squirrels eat it and they get
drunk and then they are crazy squirrels
and wait what well the fruit ferments on
the ground and the squirrels eat it and
they get shut up squirrels do not get
drunk off of ground fruit do they do and
it happens to bats to bat can no can get
drunk no no definitely a thing drunk
fruit squirrels
happened on naked and afraid to wear
this guy was really hungry and he needed
to eat food and so he ate some rotten
food and he got he got really drunk or
like he hadn't eaten in like two days so
he didn't get that drunk he didn't but
he didn't need a lot of alcohol that
fruit to make him get a little tipsy and
to be clear I only know this because I
was told this by Hannah Hart I do not
watch naked and afraid yeah that seems
like something that somebody who watches
naked and afraid would say I put naked
and afraid in Turtles all the way down
and so I felt like I had to watch an
episode of it yeah and but I watched it
I watched it after I wrote the scene you
know yes you do yeah and I watched the
show and I was like yeah no that's
pretty much what I expected I mean they
really do cover it in the title yeah
just some naked people who are pretty
afraid yeah just said pause pause the
alpha question just for a second Hank so
that we could imagine together the pitch
meeting at which naked and afraid
was created so you walk into the
Discovery Channel and and you're like
yeah we got a few shows we want to pitch
you one is about alligator hunters in
New Orleans it's called alligator town
and they're like ah alligator Tommy it
sounds good it's not great and then
you're like okay our other show is
called naked and afraid' the Discovery
Channel people are just like here is a
pile of money yeah you know what you
know we needed to do with that with-
afraid is get some people to sign some
disclaimers and put them in situations
where they might die I don't know what
the law is here going back to the apples
but I do think that somebody's got to
eat them again if it's not you it's
gonna be drunk squirrels I'm not super
worried about the public health problem
of drunk squirrels I'm a little worried
about Ken trespassing onto someone
else's land to eat someone else's apples
especially if there's an army in there
like that's not yeah I would I would
knock on the door and say hey can I pick
some of your apples or eat some of your
ground apples yeah so that the school
don't get drunk or alternately just you
know let it go which reminds me John
that this podcast is brought to you by
naked and afraid naked and afraid this
week on discovery man and a woman are
uncomfortable in the in the woods they
get bit by bugs a bunch don't you want
to watch those bug bites today's blood
guys also brought to you by Krab candy
crab candy just just don't don't
that's not a good snacks podcast is also
brought to you Tues by Tuesday tank tops
Tuesday is a brand name of new tank tops
that is available from Hank and John
Green you can get them at the space
store it's in outer space you have to
get to space that's why Elon Musk is
working so hard because he wants to get
one of those tank tops today's podcast
also brought to you by Elon Musk oh you
are musk you can get a Tesla Model 3 and
a space saver only for only sixty two
thousand dollars yeah it's thirty five
thousand dollar car that cost sixty-two
thousand dollars it's the deal of the
century
I guess but finally this podcast is
brought to you by the mouse burial
grounds where the mouse go to be
respected after death I think you're
including that which forces Nick to put
it in the pod you can't take it out now
podcast it's also brought to you by the
green brothers neck wash a joke we've
made yet to make this next question
comes from Daddy
oh you oh you're doing doing that oh
great okay thank you John the other day
I was washing my face in the shower and
I started to wonder do you use a face
wash on your neck or body wash on your
neck the neck is obviously not part of
your face but the skin seems too
sensitive for body wash help I'm
conflicted not Disney but Danny bad
jokes not sure I'm not sure that Hank
Boeing the Boeing green is in a position
to criticize other people's drew
hey I'm gonna do a Twitter poll the
podcast comes out and I'm gonna find out
what people think of that bout that joke
John I bet people gonna love it yeah
yeah no I bet Danny your neck is I'm
gonna be honest with you Danny
I just use soap on my neck up to what I
call the beard line just above my Adam's
apple uh-huh and then from there up I do
use face wash so I don't know if that's
the right way but that's my way I think
that there there is a point there my I
get sort of like dry itchy feeling on my
neck and back man like hey you could do
you do whatever you want but I do think
that like maybe there's a maybe there is
a segment of the body that doesn't have
a wash yet but the question is will we
eventually just need a rack in our
showers that's like okay well it's time
for the face it's time for the neck then
I've got my special Peck wash and then
this is for justice just for my armpits
come like do we need this is this where
we're headed as a society no no but I
think that's a great example of how yeah
like slippery slope arguments work on
Twitter yeah someone's like hey should I
use face wash below my chin and then
someone else is like oh now everything's
falling apart food will have to be great
I mean yeah fine let's just have but
just a foot wash and ankle wash and calf
wash and yyr is this even America
exactly right John that is that's that
that is not what I intended to
illustrate but I did illustrate it
through my own worrying about whether or
not we were gonna have washes for
everything all right Hank before we get
to the all-important news from Mars and
AFC Wimbledon this last question comes
from Ashley who writes dear John and
Hank I was just shopping at Marshall's
and while there I acquired an aloe vera
plantain I didn't buy it though I had an
intention of buying it I even thought I
bought it I got several other things
that I did pay for and I guess the
checkout clerk just missed ringing the
plant up what should I do
did I technically steal the plant should
I try to go back and pay for it or
should I just think of it as a gift from
the universe
that's not definitely out a gift from
the universe it's if anything it's a
gift from Marshalls because it was $4.99
if that changes it oh it does it
absolutely changes something because the
thought of driving back to Marshalls
which is gonna cost like three dollars
in gas and add to the world's carbon
emissions in order to pay for a four
dollar and 99 cent aloe vera plant is
ludicrous I mean but but you but you
didn't pay for it
no okay you didn't pay for it Hank but
it was give it was put in your cart and
you intended to pay for it and that's
just the way that it went this time it's
just and other times it will go a
different way and that stuff evens out
over a lifetime and furthermore let me
submit that in a capitalist society the
big corporations do a good enough job
extracting stuff out of you if
occasionally you get a bonus for all of
that then take your aloe vera plant and
run because God knows it isn't gonna
happen very often I'm gonna say that
next time you should take the receipt
off the plant and next time you're at
Marshall's you should you should buy it
you should buy the plant
I mean I'd love to hear from Marshalls
on this issue because I think they'd
probably be like yeah whatever Ashley I
mean as long as you're happy and you
want to come back to Marshalls at some
point we're good I bet you're right I
don't know hey I have I have definitely
done this before where I got a free
thing from the grocery store I went back
and was like I got this thing for free
can I pay for it now I'm actually gonna
tweet at Marshalls
Hey so theoretically if I accidentally
stole a plant from you no I'm not
writing that that doesn't make any sense
I'm writing hey Marshalls how do you
feel about this whole Ashley thing
question mark okay and then and then
they'll that I'd have to do the research
themselves they'll figure it out Hank
they're Marshalls
for God's sakes man they're the seventh
largest company in America all right
John well before we get to that all
important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon I have an update on the
Twitter poll from last episode yeah
where we were talking about doing
laundry for someone else I asked Twitter
I said hey if you're doing laundry for
someone else the change in their pants
pockets beat either still belongs to
them
yeah belongs to you now and most people
said that the money now belongs to you I
I why people agree with you I was right
you were wrong and Marshalls is very
confused about my question about Ashley
Hank yeah what is the news from Mars
this week it's bleak John oh no as you
all of course know the opportunity Rover
launched in 2003 it's been on Mars since
2004 so it's 14 years on Mars has been
an extremely long and successful mission
it's very exciting and very good but
they have not as sunlight has started to
come back through this dust storm that
has been covering up opportunity
preventing it from getting power through
its solar panels it is not powered back
up it is not called home and we've even
send it to some little beeps to be like
hey can you send us a beep and it hasn't
beeped back at us and it's it's whirring
and NASA does eventually have to make a
call it's a hard call to make because
this is a long mission and it's been
it's done so such amazing things and
done a lot of amazing science over the
years but the the deadline is that after
the like there's sort of an arbitrary
amount of like sunlight going through
the atmosphere it's 1.5 tau I don't know
what that unit is but when that's
reached they'll then have 45 days after
that
so once the rover is getting a certain
amount of light they get 45 days and if
the rover doesn't call home before then
the team will sort of basically disband
a little bit people will get moved to
other positions and they will continue
listen listening passively so they won't
be like active listening they listen
passively for I think until January or
something but at that point it's very
unlikely that they'll hear anything
then the rover that that team will not
be working on opportunity anymore
because they will basically have said
that opportunity is not an active
mission and everyone's pretty sure that
they won't be hearing back the good news
is that curiosity still has a lot of
mission life and also is a more robust
science experiment and has a lot of
science and is has done and will
continue to do lots of science so we do
still have an active Rover on Mars that
is a bigger better mission and are
planning another one in 2020 that is
very similar to curiosity so that's
happening and curiosity just sent back a
really beautiful selfie that it took as
the dust storm was dissipating which is
really cool and it's not powered by
solar panels it's powered by radioactive
decay and the heat caused by it so you
can't slow this boy down he's good well
I'm still very sad to hear that news
because it it has been such an
incredible run and it's such a great
story and but I guess that everything
has to end
speaking of endings oh God AFC
Wimbledon's losing streak needs to end
and soon did you win a game or something
AFC Wimbledon got four points from their
first two games a win and a draw and one
point from their most recent four games
in league one it's a very worrisome
situation in several of those games we
played brilliantly but just didn't get a
result and then after trying that
several times we thought we would try a
whole new strategy against Burton which
was to play terribly and it turned out
that also didn't work we lost that game
three nil and deserved to lose it three
nil and so now AFC Wimbledon are in 20th
place in Ligue 1 just one point away
from the relegation places back back at
the end of the table I do not enjoy
visiting huh so we're playing
Chillingham over the weekend which
should be an interesting game partly
because nobody knows for sure if
Gillingham is pronounced with a soft G
or a hard G and partly because whose
plays for Dillingham now
but former Wimbledon captain Barry
fuller whom I personally missed
desperately and it'll be nice to see him
even if he is lining up as an opponent
against AFC Wimbledon it'll be a nice
kind of homecoming hopefully we can get
a result from that game because I am
starting to get officially nervous yeah
and I I was on the the internet and it
said that you want a game in penalties
was that something else oh yeah yeah
that's one of the other competitions
oh okay so that doesn't count for points
no not in the league one season it's a
nice thing to have happened in the
Football League trophy
we played Charlton we scored two good
goals and from two players you don't
usually start for Wimbledon we also
played a pretty good game against West
Ham at the Premier League opposition
with some players who don't usually
start for Wimbledon which is starting to
make me think that maybe those players
should start for Wimbledon like some of
the younger players some of the Academy
prospects are looking pretty good at
least in those games but it's hard to
know but yeah we won that game on
penalties four to two and that means
that we might get out of the Football
League trophy group stage but my main
concern at this point is ensuring
another season in Ligue 1 since next
season is hopefully when we'll be moving
into the new stadium well best of luck I
I want sports to be good for John things
and other fans thanks I feel the same
way about Rovers on Mars Hank thank you
for potting with me it has been a
pleasure as always and thanks to
everybody for listening we're off to
record our patron only podcast this week
in Ryan's which you can get at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John but
don't worry if you can't it's not that
good this podcast is edited by Nicholas
Jenkins who this week had an even harder
job than usual so thank you Nick our
head of community and communications is
Victoria Bongiorno the podcast is
produced by rosianna halse rojas and
sheridan Gibson the music that you're
hearing right now is from the great
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]